Long ago, the town of Hamelin had a big problem of too many rats.
The people tried every way to get rid of them, but in vain.
The chief of the town declared to give ten sacks of gold...
...to anyone who saved them from the rats.
One day, a stranger from a faraway land came and told the chief...
...that he would get rid of the rats.
The stranger took out his pipe and played an odd tune.
All the rats in the town heard the music and began to follow him.
The clever man took them all to the river where all rats fell and drowned.
Finally, Hamelin was free of rats.
The pied piper went to collect his reward, but now that the problem was solved,...
...the greedy chief refused to pay him any money.
He immediately played his pipe again, this time every boy and girl of Hamelin...
...began to follow the magical music.
The pied piper took them all to a cave and closed it with a huge rock.
Two children who were left behind went to the chief and told them what happened.
The chief was very scared and ashamed of breaking his promise.
He went to the cave and begged for forgiveness.
He even promised to give the pied piper 20 sacks of gold.
Finally, the pied piper let the children go.
The town of Hamelin had learned never to be ungrateful again.